okay four people joining this meeting we
are talking about some enhancements to
off language related to annotating
things and let's see we talked last time
about how we are adding what what is the
main wrapper that we're using for
annotation what's the main idea here
rotation values it's something different
a magician that would be the one to
basically instruct or right now in the
current implementation we have for image
audio is the one that extracts the okay
so when we need so it's then advantage
lady is right and just to let me
summarize from last time we basically
were settled on having like two back
tears of annotation like for the whole
object and four parts of the object
right so annotated is four parts of the
object and for the whole object if the
whole object can have annotations there
is an annotation rules option right I
guess that was I would embed in the
object if you want to evaluate annotated
or in some other ways I pass this
annotation to the object this is one
that contains the sub part annotation
while the meta information or annotation
information if you want to just like
synchronize the names with the the one
that keeps with the big high tier
association that always working towards
documenting all of the stuff and so on
right now we are like very I mean this
is a design that we came up last time
but we we have a prototype for audio
which is the best more fleshed out right
now but we were waiting to see what this
design was going before actually
committing to write there are some
documentation pages based on a very
early audio annotation design okay but
but so here just to understand what
we're planning here is um
so had we settled on
okay so functions that return annotated
stuff audio annotate will add
annotations will attempt to add
annotations to something correct yes
okay
and
okay so annotation value for a given
interval what it's annotating speaker it
would try to return that right now what
an addition value is doing in the
current design is basic and like to know
if it's called property value for graph
is a mutable frame so if you if you say
it's not there's a mutable okay which we
change that now yeah so can and graphs
will be changed to use this stuff and to
remove the property values I mean we'll
have to keep supporting property value
but we're not going to document it going
forward right Charles
I'm sure as well this one actually
provide this set of functionality make
sure it does because we want to get rid
of property value right because that was
a bad name and we don't want to use it
it's super confusing so tell me what
that provides that you think might be a
problem well I'm just seeing the design
now I'm not haven't you been in these
meetings before no that's my first
meeting but that is at first glance it's
you know it's it's kind of awfully
similar we have you know an extract of
something to sell we call it property
value here is a mutation annotated which
is again something where you put the
wrapper that says annotated around
something exactly yes now I could
imagine and Brett this is for you I
could imagine in graphic something could
say annotated and then something could
say things that are annotated in such
and such a way should be rendered in
such in such a way
right
right
I mean I would think so I mean I'm again
the I'm with Charles this is our first
exposure to this so oh wow
okay okay well let's go through it more
carefully though okay so let's talk
about so some things are rappers that
have a place to put annotations like
image has a place to put annotations
what image doesn't have so image the
whole outer wrapper can have an
annotation information which is the
equivalent of the meta information stuff
right okay okay so then within an image
there could be in addition annotation
rules which say this pixel you know this
block of pixels
whatever it is no we can say pixel 1 1 2
pixel 550 seventy that's aware and the
value is arrow object type arrow horse
let's say okay so that would be a way of
annotating that image to indicate that
um at that pixel location is a horse
am I making sense now I think that
what's the difference between annotation
information Annunciation rules
annotation information refers to the
whole whole object I see okay and
whereas this is where and then what I
mean I suppose one could have an all
arrow whatever there but I'm not sure
that that's a good thing also because
the meta information really contains
some stuff about like X if tags and
other things I know I mean I don't know
what exactly what the future of meta
information is supposed to be here but
the more general thing is this
annotation information was like I don't
see the all those axis thing mixing very
well with this where and what structure
between fermentation rules yes
and obviously that could have the the
flip around which is the association
here that says what and then the wares
yeah yeah we were discussing this last
time I mean we I don't know if one will
be sitting especially meta-information
is largely for the whole object rather
than a part of the object you know it's
like what camera was used to take this
picture and what was the settings for it
and a little bit stores other workflow
in from yes that's exactly what we're
saying right yeah okay so then so
annotation rules is inside a wrapper
like image then there's the possibility
that you could have something like five
six annotated expression comma blah blah
blah
okay so that's relevant for other kinds
of things um but even text that's a
little bit challenging and I'm going to
talk about that we're about to talk
about that so how is annotated different
from annotation well annotation is an
old thing that does something is
slightly different okay which will be
which will be deprecated
okay so annotation does that weird thing
where it happens to be displaying
something in the footer well I can do
lots of things it doesn't have to
display things in the footer
yeah well this is interesting
I agree that's functionality we need the
point of annotated is that one could
have something for example in a time
series where some part of the time
series is annotated do you see what I'm
saying well you want to put that wrapper
in there I mean I mean it's just a
convenient input form it would never be
stored that way obviously makes no sense
yeah I understand it when it was itself
to the Container on evaluation
well I okay it will be stripped in
parsing rather than sewing whatever
however you want to do it um so the
question is whether annotated so I mean
an alternative here what a mess what
does the default do was the default
annotation do do you know nothing
so it just sits there it just sits there
I mean it's you know for just displays
thing well we could use the same rapper
probably because because this annotated
as by the way we've got a bunch of
background noise please um you know we
probably could use the same rapper now
that I'm looking at it because the third
argument you know saying what to do with
the annotation that would actually fit
in just fine because it could say what
is regions for rasterize export etc what
does that mean that is to facilitate
image maps so for example if you have a
scene you know it's a bunch of disks and
you take one of the disks and you read
annotation or whatever region around it
well then you export race you can pixel
position of the disc well but that's not
I mean to make an image map well I'm not
quite sure what that the I this was I'm
fairly certain this was tied into HTML
export in some way yes that's what I
think too I don't remember the details
but I'm but that's that was the idea
though right but this isn't completely
stupid even with with annotated and then
a third argument here which says you
know tooltip for example
hyperlink for exported image maps
huh okay but one could imagine something
where the third argument here says how
to indicate the annotated thing for
display purposes and normally it
wouldn't be indicated for display
purposes we just sit there for semantic
purposes and not have a display
representation I'm making sense so I
mean in most compound objects that would
be makes no sense
what do you mean like time series it
makes no sense whatsoever but and what
makes no sense that one data value is
annotated with a hyperlink makes no
sense wait wait wait wait no that's not
correct if it if you have a time series
okay wait wait wait let's take the case
of audio okay we perfectly well know
that we want to annotate audio in
intervals at least to say that speaker 1
speaker 2 and so on right hmm so with
time series and we talked about this at
the end of last time the relationship
between discrete and continuous
annotation okay so for example you know
in a time series it could be you know
rocket was launched here in the time
series am i making sense sure but it
wouldn't do an actual hyperlink there's
no where the hell do you point to to get
the hyperlink no I I get it I get it I
get it but I mean look the fact is well
it might or why not I mean who knows it
could say something like this it could
say you know whatever the rocket
launched you know data is you know time
value um and then it could say you know
HTTP you know rocket launch comm or
something okay and then it could say
hyperlink and if we wanted it to that
would mean I mean I'm not sure what that
mean I don't know
mean to look that these things seem like
they have been grandfathered for
particularly you know that they're being
used for multiple purposes and I this
documentation is completely inadequate
yeah I don't understand why there isn't
more documentation here there's nothing
here this is kind of lame
okay just we need to know what this
actually does
so let's look raster eyes maybe that has
a comment about what's going on here
okay regions
possible basic elements that can be
returned by rasterize include okay so
that's a weird thing
John do you understand this no but I can
I can try digging into it a bit
would you like an example Stephen yeah
okay I see it down here look rasterize
because the list of rules of the form
so zero validation
hmm okay that's really funky I mean this
is so got go ahead come in example oh
well I mean there might be one further
down which is you know probably easier
than typing but
there's
[Music]
you
that's really funky so it gives bounding
boxes mm-hmm you know in the pixel
coordinates of the rasterized graphic
okay all right so look there's some
there's some uses here that we need to
understand but fundamentally whether
it's called annotated or annotation and
it's possible that we might want to
rename it annotated um and basically
deprecated annotation taking over its
functionality with annotated but the
main thing for annotated is that we want
to give this you know key value list
right of what and value by making sense
yeah yes people understand no they don't
understand I mean for annotated the what
is the first argument right
no look at what it says no no no no what
what this means is annotated and you can
give some you know expert comma and then
here it says speaker arrow you know Bob
or something
yo what I'm saying arrow emotion state
this will be for audio arrow happy get
what I'm saying
I think so so the corresponding value
path so the correspondence between
annotation and annotation rules is that
annotation annotated you know that
expert centrally serves as where for the
annotation exactly exactly
this is this is specifying it by
symbolic structure as opposed to
specifying it by giving the position so
to speak gotcha
okay
okay so there are these two cases but
those cases I want to emphasize are work
only for things where you can insert the
stuff so as Roger pointed out so so for
example for an image you can't get
inside the image to do this right if you
if your data is represented as a list
you could get inside the data and do
this okay what I'm saying
whereas for an image you're not gonna
break the image apart and say there's no
way to wrap around those particular
pixels with something so instead you
have to refer to it indirectly by saying
this region in the picture does this
that makes sense yes okay
so now let's consider the case of
strings
okay what's that shiny that was shoddy
yes yes hey which shot he was away for
yes but it's now bad good or is not or
is on the other side no I'm back I'm
back as of yesterday okay terrific
congratulations um okay so okay so let's
talk about strings right again you the
so what we considered here which is
perhaps crazy is the possibility of
exploding a string into something like
this
to be able to annotate it alternatively
yeah I mean that seems hopeless actually
well I think it seems like a really good
idea to me
it already has ahead for God's sake yes
I mean it's no entry that's ok just can
still query
well can we comment on the on them
understand that is this thing string Q
for example and what would happen if you
said string take yeah that's the real
problem is that you have all kinds of
functions which expect to be able to
work on strings and fundamentally assume
that a string is nothing more and
nothing less than an array of characters
yeah so we might have to create just
four for that reason that that need to
be sort of a hyper string or something
yeah so you know I had a concept of
something that is like a better linear
syntax that involves markup that lives
you know inside a string but is
fundamentally still string ish it's a
not one that I've floated generally and
as may have some controversy to it but
you know it's an idea that I've been
kind of you know tumbling around for a
little while now so women I mean linear
syntax but there are other kinds of
things that people want to like the
machine learning people want to annotate
strings with entities right I think this
was Jerome's thing where he's eating and
and this is very complicated because
this has a lot of overlapping annotation
right in fact the only way this
annotation can reasonably be represented
I think is by giving a kind of offline
you know this range to this range right
so it's the very same as for audio yes
but but but notice that this type of in
in expression annotation can only work
hierarchically you can't have disjoint
selections there yeah so it's
limitation of that right so that's a
conveyed previously is that's a
convenience when you can use it sure
when you can't just use the annotation
rules to indicate where the things
should be so in a sense and this would
again for Strings
I mean I'm skeptical about okay so
question for John so I mean the problem
with linear syntax right now and for
those who want to know what we mean by
this I mean so if we say this and we say
control gosh it's been so long since I
did this control equals let's say X
cubed I've done what I typed here um
you're not using that often I'm not
using this very often no I it's a
magnificent feature that that I was
gonna say that's a good thing that he's
not using this that often why just
because of all the problems that linear
syntax you know no I wasn't referring to
death he's not using the superscript and
subscript okay okay so now what is this
string Splore f-- okay now the problem
is if i take that string line to and I
say string take a percent 2 comma 10 for
example what am I going to get you'll
get something that it corrupts the
structure but it doesn't break string
take
yes I understand and and I think there's
some merit to that okay so let's talk
about by the way why on earth is this
indicating as a syntax error oh because
it is oh my gosh what a horrifying thing
because that string is no longer a
syntactically usable string I'm not a
hundred percent certain if that's and
I'm not for sure if that's confusing
there might be a bug I mean you know I
don't know I don't know okay but let's
talk let's talk for a minute about
linear syntax okay you know the real
question is is this a string I mean what
could we possibly do okay so let's talk
about what some things that we could do
I mean you know string take what is
string take and is supposed to do one a
thing like this it seems quite hopeless
I think it kind of has to do exactly
what it does yeah people actually do
this right now in doing horrible awful
things that would that would make you go
you know running for the hills screaming
but they do it in order to accomplish
real ends yeah but so the question is is
there a more elegant way to handle this
stuff
I mean because what we've got here is an
escape inside the string and then
actually it's it's very difficult in the
form that it's in right now for it to be
elegant because linear syntax is the
parsing gets much much worse than what
you're seeing here the this looks like
straightforward and you could kind of
figure it out but you're not even close
to the
case scenario here well okay be that as
it may I'm asking the question you know
20 20 something years later would we
have done the NIR syntax different light
well does that look boxes are for no
well so the I mean in answer to Brett's
question you know this is a fundamental
problem is that for most things you know
boxes in the front end or directly
analogous to boxes which are sent over
the link to the kernel
but this completely not you know we have
to have this parser for this form you
know between you know something that's
sent to the kernel as a string and boxes
and for the front end but so for that
scenario it's really it's really like we
say it's a linearization it's a it's
it's it's a streaming format to get that
information over this sort of a kacct
format for it yeah yeah exactly for the
front end it would be easier if we just
dealt with everything as boxes you know
all of this typesetting stuff instead of
strings but then but then the only
possible you know results would be
either that we just you know voice the
problem on to the kernel of linearizing
it or we give up on linearize in it and
we break string cake and friends okay so
actually there's a number of interesting
comments on our live stream here the
most recent one of which is why isn't
the stuff inside backslash XCOM treated
as a single character let's examine that
question for a second okay in the world
where we had only two byte characters in
strings that was clearly not sensible
because it's kind of you know it breaks
the information theory so to speak we're
trying to stuff a large amount of
information into a single character but
in the modern world where strings can
have multi byte characters why is that
so obviously stupid so in other words
imagine that
what happened is for purposes of string
cake that thing is just a lump it's just
a single character lump it happens to be
it's not a four character it's not a
four byte character it's an 82 by two
character but it's just one character
what is wrong with that idea well I mean
the you know of course the first issue
is that it's something that has to be
implemented fundamentally in kernel
strings and I'm not sure what the
consequences of doing that are they
could be quite dramatic in what sense I
mean just but but but semantically it
seems like that that seems like a quite
sensible suggestion well I mean so how
is a function like string take
implemented in the kernel the the kind
of structure you're talking about is no
longer a simple array of characters but
okay so my question is this but you have
a full byte character I don't know what
it looks like internally when you have a
string that is mostly one byte
characters and then suddenly there's a
piece of you know Babylonian Kanaya form
in there that's wow right now in in
nightly builds right now everything is a
single 32 but each character is a single
32-bit value a string in the kernel is a
list of you know basically 32-bit
integers representing characters we can
just quadruple the size of every string
did we they were 16-bit before but yes
some things got larger
that's not nice so in other words
there's no mixed string there's no
there's nothing where there's an 8-bit
character humph
that's right now I'm not the one who
implemented it and I'm not the kernel
expert but my understanding from the
people who did is yes that's that's the
way it is so it's a packed form
well what's packed about it wait a
minute just does 11:3 have the new
string stuff in it no fact you said it's
an
ray of 30 yeah it's it's an array so
it's packed you know an egg Stevens
complaint is that it's packed with a
larger data type
okay so the bite count there is 32 so
let's go look at can I look in the in
the head branch builders yes in the
perfect yes didn't yeah it's been in
head branch for months
so yeah alright so let's take a look
here um wake up you know I'm not getting
used to this thing being at the top do
you really want it at the top John oh
sorry I'm not sure it's there are
difficulties let's not discuss it here
but there are difficulties okay and you
are gonna get rid of the stupid period
at the end there
Oh is there a period and it's 150 period
percent oh yeah yeah well magnificently
that's still 32 bytes wait a minute is
that is that what I would expect hold on
a second so if I say string join of the
alphabet or something and I say byte
count of that I would expect it is
okay now what's it going to do here now
if I go
okay well that's cool a good sign so
let's say I say here Greek alphabet 80
characters okay great
magnificent so let's say I say here okay
well this is all good now how do I get
to a character anybody know the Unicode
for some weird emoji sorry that it's one
[Music]
I'm trying to remember the when I get to
an emoji on my Mac keyboard no no and
you won't be able to see it in any case
fine but how would I how would I so if I
simply say
you know it's X 0 1 F 6 0 0 is smiling 0
1 F 6 0 0 but you won't be able to see
it on Mac though okay fine
it'll it'll look like - unknown - weird
glyphs why - we're cliffed oh because of
the following because of the lack of
front-end support ok but so that is a
string right yeah
ok so if I say characters of that string
I will see it oh what oh no no that's
that's something went terribly wrong
there that should not happen ok so I
died somehow yeah yeah the colonel died
I will follow up on that
I died so we couldn't really tell did it
die or did it who knows what happened
that yeah yeah it seen the a doubt label
yeah I see it
okay well the good news here is that
these things are not any bigger so
that's that's great although we don't
know how that's achieved well the bad
news is this thing seems to be
completely dead on arrival
um but I think we should I mean
semantically this seems like an
interesting suggestion to treat anything
which isn't a I mean I have no idea what
what is involved in the way that this I
mean clearly we have to know something
about this implementation but
semantically if the extra weird stuff in
the string was treated as a single
character that would work for everything
I mean it will work for string take it
would make sensible semantics for string
take etc right and the only thing we
wouldn't have there is we would need a
separate function to basically box if I
well how would we box if I yeah to
basically turn into boxes that thing we
need a function that goes backwards and
forwards between the single composite
character and the boxes that stand for
that that that single character stands
for right yeah well we'd have to invent
an entirely new notion of string boxes
right well anyway this is the least
silly suggestion that I've heard for how
to you know because if we did that then
then all of this writing out well okay
so then how does it serialize that's the
next question so it could serialize the
exact same way it c realizes today right
it's just semantically character you
know character by character it would be
something different although that
unfortunately might be an incompatible
change I don't understand this form is
to serialize boxes and notebook
expressions why don't we just assign the
correct sir
inform for it and not let it mix with
strings sir lies what I mean but the
string look within a string you can have
an inline cell right that's what this is
the thing I just created here is I mean
even even if I'm doing something very
basic I'm saying the what it reminds me
I'm guessing for version 3 or whenever
this was introduced I'm guessing that
was introduced as a bridge because some
functions will prepare for anything but
strings like messages or somesuch but
but there are all kinds of cases where
you want to deal with strings the I mean
among other things you know I deal with
strings for things which are not you
know syntactic input of any form right
but you need to hold that representation
in some way and the oh you could hold it
as pourings or to work directly with the
boxes which then introduces its own set
of confusions if you're doing that in
your code well I mean but to be fair you
know there are things like subscript for
example you know which are just fine you
can do that in your code without any
trouble yeah well let's let's roll back
just a minute let's think about this
again for a second so when was this
introduced this was introduced in
version 3 right that's right so that's
like mid-90s 1996 but oh yeah I knew
that it's always easy to remember my
oldest child was one year old at the
time um August in 96 right they okay
so and remind me John why did we
introduce the linear syntax well so I
mean okay ultimately it comes down to
this the in the front end when you have
a typesetting editor
the we feel that it's important that you
should be able to type anything okay now
obviously not anything that you type is
going to evaluate we need to be able to
represent it in boxes but not everything
you type is going to evaluate but then
the question is should you impose some
kind of artificial limitation around
strings you could but that actually
denies a lot of fairly useful sorts of
behaviors you know you want to kind of
piece together you know bits of you know
typesetting things that you know using
yet and you know pass them around you
know as not evaluating expressions but
just as you know it's something that
draws but wait a minute I mean we've
always got the possibility I mean if we
have something like this right then that
thing okay
I mean you know simple case you want to
do radical of X you know you want to
pass do you want to do square root of
unevaluated of X just put it a string
string of radical of X no string
what are you telling me square root of x
all right all right string of sorry
control 2 of X a string of control 2 of
X yes by being in a string you don't
ever have to worry about what's gonna
happen with that X it didn't create a
symbol it didn't and you know it won't
evaluate it is what it is it will never
change yeah I understand I mean it's a
way of taking an expression I mean look
we could have instead had a thing called
quote we do we have a thing called hold
right I mean if I
say that yeah I mean you know one could
have done this with old form I don't
remember if we had hold for adversity we
did yeah we did but I don't think that
I'd I don't think this was the only
point I think there were a lot of cases
where you had to go back and forth what
was the point here um well okay let's
come back to our current issue I do
think we should re-examine linear syntax
some more and I think I mean there are
cases that you know that deal with
strings exclusively I mean you did
mention messages that is definitely one
of them I mean with that legacy to this
very day yes I mean the thing is there
are things which operated a low-level
just on strings and I understand that
you know by the time it's okay let's
come back to our main issue for right
now which is annotation of strings okay
so you know I think string annotation is
a fairly special case he says I mean is
string annotation fundamentally
different from bitmap annotation or or
sound annotation I mean no you mean you
cannot really sorts of things in terms
of you know applying positional
information from the outside yeah that's
correct
there the only difference is that the
image wrapper you know if I do
if I have a little tiny image but to me
it seems like a waste to have create
just annotated string I think there
should be a more capable object and just
you know it's like seems like a waste of
symbols you know you can build a rich or
string interface if you you know if you
build a real let's just current string
is like raw string gem saying yeah yeah
yeah
I'm trying to figure out if for example
I mean are there different kinds of
Anna's his trains which deserve their
own head or should it be more general
than that I mean like is a spoken
language string different from I don't
know from a genetic data string or
something
yeah well the fact that we represent
genome stuff I mean you know the fact
that we're saying whatever it is Wow
what are those that's so we treat those
the same as English then because the
strings the strings we do yes we do I
mean this thing well that wasn't very
exciting let's pick up let's pick who
knows a small gene anyway whatever okay
so I mean that for us is just a yeah
it's just like English yeah and we can
say string take and all that all the
usual things now obviously we would like
to be able to annotate that and say you
know this is the such-and-such region of
that gene we want that
patien you know we could want two
different things to happen we could want
it to be the case that when you do
string take you carry the annotation
along I mean things that are useful for
for a higher level string you know it
could have some display effects so the
string gets displayed with different
colors alright but that's what's going
on here right this annotation here of
the string which is right you can change
you know you can make it thicker some
you know like boulders or something
right well it's highlighting underlying
and so on yeah right but that if this if
that's carried with the object then it's
always there yes but then what does
string take to does it drop it or does
it not you know it should probably drop
it well but that's probably not what you
want some of the time because time what
you want is you might want it to follow
along but that's what we talked about
for annotations to that huh you know or
properties for graphs how can you make
them follow along when you have an
operation that produce a new object of
the same type you know I mean you could
define an algebra of string operations
that you know that functions on the
annotation data sure right so the
question would be if you do a string
take let's say you've annotated a
particular block of characters as a
string tag for this would be a more
sophisticated it would in particular it
would use part of it would be the old
raw string tape that we have and part of
it when it gets this kind of object it
needs to do a more sophisticated
operation yeah but let's take an example
to see what it would do so let's say one
is annotated a range of characters in a
string to be I don't know
indicated that it's a noun phrase or
something right and either a raw string
take two character number 11 which bites
off part of the noun phrase and not the
rest of the noun phrase what do you then
do with the noun phrase that the
annotation has to you know we have to
know whether the annotation in that case
is atomic or not I suit you say and that
becomes part of the algebra I was
talking about I see
so I usually things that a higher-level
string could do it
could allied you know it could also
allied you could specify how much to
elide so you don't get this many page
string for instance alright so this is
the notion of a higher level string or a
wrapped string so to speak um okay so is
an annotation an atomic ie if only part
of it is taken okay I give you another
example something ugly should the should
the annotation drop off
okay so here's another case is the
annotation unique as in what does it do
so if you copy that part of the string
does the annotation repeat so I'm saying
mm-hmm so that that would be you know a
like like for instance I don't know you
know sort of first first noun well you
don't want first noun to go repeat
repeat repeat
if you repeat the string so okay so
another thing you've mentioned is auto
elision um okay but so there might also
be some cases where I mean like in the
text case difficult exactly how to
express this but like in the text case
you know you diagram a sentence and so
this is the subject but you take the
word out you still taken the whole word
out but it's not in a sentence anymore
so it can't be a subject what you're
saying you know it could still be a noun
but it can't be a subject then those
things
string whatever place and stuff like
that which I think have even more I last
defining this kind of thing right so
when our live stream is asking why the
list of a string a comma string B can't
be equal to the concatenated string
because they mean something different
imagine that I wanted the words in this
sentence I would I might want to do
something with the words in the sentence
that's different from having the
sentence itself
but-but-but-but okay so that then the
next case here was a word in a sentence
in sit you could be a subject but when
extract it can't be but again that could
be a mess because when extracted too far
it can't be but if the sentence from a
paragraph maybe it still is yeah okay
there's nothing that guarantees the
connotations are about the text
structure they could be they could be
literally whatever thing they use are
thinks of I'm sorry what do you mean so
team in and I don't think we have
discussed any restriction to the content
of the annotation no I understand but it
could also be that this word is said
with emphasis or something yes and then
very very unclear what's that well just
the color blue that could be a valid
imitation well I think we want
annotations that say key value so to
speak so okay yeah but what you're
saying here is there is an ocean as John
is saying there's an algebra of
annotations basically is that something
that will be true of expressions as well
we have the same issue right a minute
it's it's there's nothing special about
a string versus a except the expressions
are you know they already have an
algebra because we have a full
expression manipulation language so one
could imagine annotations that sit you
know where the lists know P okay so look
that there could be annotations of of
strings versus annotations of lists we
could equally well have whatever the
annotator is you know what whatever
let's just imagine that we said
annotated of a string comma and then we
broke what I was saying before which
isn't very good but but
yeah I mean and then we had a you know
where arrow what a sequence of where Oh
what type things we could imagine doing
exact same thing with a list right I'm
not sure how useful that would be but
but um we've got the list elements there
and then we potentially got operations
so if we defined I mean again I'm not
certain what we want to do there but we
could define a take operation that would
take on annotated with a certain algebra
of how that works well so this was I'm
not sure if I understood roger correctly
earlier or not but it kind of sounded
like there were some cases where where
roger was concerned about you know that
you do have a list but violating the
integrity of that is expensive or
undesirable for some reason well yes and
no but it wasn't that big of I was I
think that listen when we talk about the
annotation you're referring to I think
in the time series want to monkey with
the packed array basically by putting
something like that in there but it also
makes no sense because you can't point
to that individual point it's not there
you there's nothing that that's why I
was saying you're saying in a time
series you have certain control points
basically but the the there could be a
point where something exciting happened
but that point is not actually
explicitly represented in the input data
so it should be there too but then you
wouldn't have marked it up with your
discrete annotated thing to begin you
couldn't it might have been the case
that the thing has a time series where
you know just linear interpolation is
being done you know the temperature is
rising whatever you know one degree
curve per minute or something and at
some moment you want to annotate the
fact that they've passed the boiling
point of lead or whatever sure but that
wouldn't use annotated it would use the
options where no I agree it would use
the options I agree right right so it
isn't there you can't wrap annotate it
around exactly yes
right and yeah so I mean the question
the one on the live stream is asking
about plotting when there are
annotations yes I mean one wants ways to
display annotations and to have options
for how the annotations of different
kinds could be displayed but I think the
problem we're trying to solve right here
you know I so we can we can trade just a
just a to make it concrete so we haven't
come as far yet with with audio but
right now the plots on the audio plots
and so on functions do display where the
annotations are over time one could
imagine how do I see that if I say audio
capture here there should be in the
prototype okay let me see I want to see
this okay um let me then talk about
another case which is much far too
developed which is graphs and meshes
mm-hmm
now the vertex color the vertex shape
the vertex label are all properties
their standard properties that we
support and there's more there are their
weights there are capacities these are
standard things that we system-wide
support everything else is user
extensible and those are displayed a
weight service plate how weights weights
are not displayed but but the color and
in the shape and so on they are
displayed but by the way does somebody
know the prototype build seems to be as
the prototype built broken or is the
prototype build just not package scope
make interpreter object anybody
recognize that I don't know I think this
is a modern build a modern build yeah it
will break some syntax stuff but it's no
fear okay fine um okay so now I say
audio capture
okay stone that and hello hello hello
so now you want to annotate it some
hours so you say don't say audio plot
what is that okay so that doesn't that
okay now how do i annotate it you might
want to say audio annotate of out to and
maybe audible the string audible I
should do something radically let's see
okay and now all your plot of that
command notations goes to audible the
how to select which one's is still not
like this I think so yeah
there should be the current state
interesting okay nothing is final it's
just something to like play on and see
these annotations are useful essentially
all right so so that was so the bottom
area of the audio plot is showing the
annotation and it could say you know my
name or something there if it recognized
my voice or whatever yeah right okay and
you could imagine more things that that
automatically use these so for instance
we could have an extended player in the
future which allows you to do karaoke
right it tells you what to sing or its
transcribed a speech so you see it's
just amazing that we can have a whole
technology stack and in the end we make
a karaoke machine bad stats right what
else would you do okay so it'll be the
world's first symbolic karaoke machine
[Laughter]
we're gonna be singing math formulas
yeah right we have that right we have
all kinds of don't we have a spoken
string thing for for CSS someone use of
annotations in the audio domain is just
to information about the signal in the
same object this is have been used in
while there other than for actual
computation on the signal and there's a
bunch of sort of very technical things
like like linguists they like to store
phonemes and other things for for
training data and other stuff right okay
but let's come back to this case and
understand how it maps into what we've
talked about here okay so audio annotate
is adding
conceptually things like annotation
rules yes into the audio object exactly
the format of the data is like a
different is the same kind of
information it's exactly now the
exposure of that through audio plot is
the case we have not discussed so we
discussed annotation value as so
annotation value here would be
potentially a way of that that is
implemented that should work
Oh what would should it do the data
structure cool ok and it has several
utilities the second argument is the one
that you asked for the selection where
you can ask for an interval but you can
also have a pure function as a criterion
like return all the information all the
annotation that for that satisfy this
criterion and it's kind of you could ask
time is lot time something slot whatever
I'm not a huge fan of this I don't quite
understand why this isn't a time
interval yeah so as I said the data
structure is different the information
is the same ok this allows them to have
one uniform way for zero duration which
is an event to positive duration which
is an interval fair enough
and if you want a value of outcome oh
come interval that gets from muttered as
intervals like this I think all food mod
might work as well actually an interval
as a string I think yeah that should do
it
hopefully that was true no no
there is something wrong anyways the
third argument does their formatting if
you want to whatever there is some issue
determines how the thing is returned
association was a graphic or something
yeah I'm serious for example yeah okay
alright but let's look at the case we
have not considered as this case here
which says what to do with the
annotations in for example a plot right
so that's a case we haven't discussed in
our annotation value so I think the
correct thing for that would be
something like um I'm going to okay so
we might oh yeah it specifies well yes
or we could also have annotation style
by weight that is already implemented
that you so you can apply different
styling to the in audio plot how you go
annotation style goes to add for example
that applies the style to the plot of
the annotation I it's just convenient
stuff it's not we haven't discussed the
design of these things so but just so
you know that there should be something
that percent percent is nothing
resentful
no yeah percent for the other men
percent you know your plot should be
okay we should do it okay magnificent
all right but but so then the question
is annotation options or annotation
style I think annotation style is the
right thing for plotting given that the
thing you're plotting has annotations in
it annotation style to none annotation
style is some um yeah so we have various
comments on our live stream here let me
just take a look at these um
so Ethan black 86 is pointing out I
think the best way to think about
annotations is in the context of
expressing arbitrary metadata on samples
in some training data set that's one use
case yes um let's see
examples two labels I see I see I see
what you're saying is instead of in a
training set what you could do is you
could say here are five pictures to
three R of cats tour of dogs where you
where you represent that by saying um
you know picture arrow cat picture arrow
dog right the alternative would be that
you could say that the picture itself
was annotated with the label right you
can also
have a picture with many things in it
you know so your honor absolutely but
where is to count Paris dog okay the
good point that's being made in my view
is that for the machine learning folk
there is the what am I trying to say um
the um sorry I sent
um for the machine learning folks they
probably want the things like classify
to work directly on things that just
have annotations that don't have
labeling am I making sense so that's
another place where you're exposing it's
a place where you're using annotations
right where you're you're training on
the annotations rather than training on
labor on labels does that make sense
what do you mean by label what's your
what I mean is is normally when you say
classify right it looks like this you
say picture you know some picture arrow
cat some picture or dog right but the
alternative would be that within the
picture is an annotation that says this
is a picture you know oh I see
annotation information yeah I see what
you're saying okay alternative here
would be a notation
well that within that picture so let's
imagine it was an image and it could say
our notation information arrow cat and
all it is is annotated images right
right there's no explicit value that's a
really good point I mean that that that
that should be used as a that it should
be possible to do that let's see whose
project managing here tell me that it's
me Steven Parker
okay slightly off your usual beat but
still that's something we should point
out to Etienne and friends um okay we'll
do the somebody's pointing out this
thing called audio set do we know about
audio set yes yep excuse for all you
identify oh so that's by the way to kiss
audio identify work yes okay I have to
try this sorry I haven't never tried
this before let's do this oops it's
gonna say fake cough oh it's gonna say
nothing the problem is that the settle
of label says Wow okay that might have
some issues for I'll check that out the
problem is that the set of labels that
are available in on your set is very
limited so it will not have something as
specific as call I see I'm saying the
set of labels is five hundred versus
five thousand for a magenta Phi
right right right right okay in any case
but but back to this point that we need
a way so in the case of graphics we're
saying pull out the annotation and use
it in such and such a way right use it
to you know display it in such and such
a way displayed as a tooltip display it
as a red box or something similarly in
the case of machine learning we have to
say pull out the annotation and use it
to give for example the labels so that's
another another issue is right
the graphics labeling or machine
learning etc okay um I think we're in
just a beginning of all the potential
workflows with this well fair enough but
but that comes back okay so let's go
back it's there so quick question
something you said just triggered this
so for that classify example mm-hmm how
does it know that the you know can't
inside the annotation information for
that picture is an object and not you
know the camera type or whatever if it's
well exactly that's why I'm saying you
need to be able to say what you're going
to use that is classified would
otherwise be learning you know it's like
it's like when the perceptron learnt
that it was you know that it was a tank
during the day type thing it's learning
the wrong thing image identify identify
what camera took photos yes but the
whole point is that that what we want to
do here is to say in the classified
thing we want to be able to have a
wrapper that effectively causes this to
turn into something like this right that
that somehow you know it's like
annotation value but it unscrambles you
know
it somehow unscrambles the annotated
thing but essentially surfaces you know
annotations to use for some other
purpose so can I give you one example so
it's thinking of a similar thing for
example if you have an audio object
that's annotated why do you want to just
block the annotation and I was wondering
if it was possible to teach for example
this line plot to taken or the object
and extract the annotation do the
correct thing turns out that that's
fairly so the workaround seemed sensible
to my mind was to give the third
argument to annotation value that allows
you to format the output in whatever way
you prefer I would generate some some
intermediate symbolic form that can then
be consumed by lists line plot and other
things that's exactly what he said yeah
I mean you know it it just helps with
the wrangling there's several standard
ways of percent you know outputting it
but it's not just symbolic it does
evaluate to that yes it's symbolic in
the sense that the thing it evaluates to
is a symbolic object but yeah okay I get
it
okay so let's let's zoom out for a
second and talk about strings again um
let's see somebody is asking
different region dimensions of your
object for example for audio for once to
have a the region that's louder than
some threshold yeah that's the whole
idea of this being a bunch of key value
pairs yeah
examining and associations of the
closest will be keys yeah yeah that's
correct the okay so the suggestion there
is because this is a that that's that
that's a reasonable suggestion that that
the because this thing is normally in
the form of an association what one
could do here okay so this is a way to
do this I agree so this is if we said
this and then the whole shebang
were to say arrow class I think that
might be consistent with the whole might
conceivably be consistent with the whole
structure of what classify can take to
have that then extract that key value
from the annotation information of all
those images I was thinking about this
theorem but this is to me I'm not sure
if fair enough maybe that the right
thing to do is I mean so so alternative
would be something like um I don't know
see it's got to have some way to pull
this out it's got to be some wrapper to
pull this out annotation maybe is to
keep limitation value unevaluated for
certain inputs but the point I don't
think that's kind of I don't think
that's gonna fly because I think that's
gonna be confusing let's really look
that's really fragile any let's let's go
back to the strings great case okay so I
think what we're understanding here is
that we're gonna need something that is
a fairly specific you know that's an
annotated string okay so so let's see so
let's
say these were this is a mess my notes
here but but um but I gets a whole
design project to design a higher level
string and I think it's kind of a waste
of space just annotated
don't you yeah
and it means I mean yes we've already
got this whole mechanism and text
element for example I mean like this
thing wherever I had it this thing here
is already its own I mean if I if I go
to this and then I do input form of that
thing it looks like that
it's a hierarchical now notice this is
hierarchical this is based on the trees
framework basically it's a hierarchical
annotation but it could not deal with
disjoint annotation right um and you
know maybe this is the wrong way wrong
thing for text structure to return I
don't know I mean it's been useful I I
mean I think once the trees framework is
up and running it may be better to
return something of that type by default
at least so I mean your point about a
higher level string I mean it really is
annotations I mean what else is there
gonna be about a higher level string
other than annotations it's a string
together with certain metadata that may
be dependent on the where the metadata
has certain attributes like is it an
atomic annotation now by the way all
this stuff about is the annotation
atomic that's gonna come up in other
places well it's going to come up an
audio for example right so it's so like
for example let's say you've tagged this
is a phony okay and then you do an audio
take and you get half the phoneme what
should you do I mean if that's being
used for some machine learning training
set you probably want to say forget it
it's not a phoneme just drop that label
get what I'm saying
okay so we've just designed a mechanism
to deal with inheritance properly for
graphs that we're implementing is that
that's one of the biggest requests that
were there so we have properties and
have been extensively used all kinds of
in Harold's proto
and people out there doing amazing
things with it so that's been
exceedingly useful now because it makes
it extensible now what we're going to do
is that the the set of operations that
takes a graph or several graphs and
produce a new one we we're you know and
like that you can specify for the
particular property you want it to
propagate or not so is it going to be
inherited and say from where it comes
you know something what what happens
exactly this one of the tricky cases you
know so but the thing is that it gives
both individual it gives you override
control over these operations sometimes
you don't want it you just want the
clean thing but sometimes you want it to
sort of you know there's automatic or
you can say exactly what right right but
what you're saying is the calculus of
annotations is alive and well and has to
be applied in graphs as well as in
strings because you have the same issue
if you have a sub graph when you extract
that sub graph but the whole the whole
of some sub graph was annotated as being
this is the production line in the
factory or something and then you
extract a sub graph there's a disjoint
part of that right
you know something sub graph some people
really want the coordinates the
embedding coordinates to be preserved so
that's that's in fact a property for us
it's not part of it the raw graph is
just a structural thing there's nothing
to do with embedding so you know and
it's done but but what you're saying is
what you're saying is that this whole
idea of inheritance of annotations right
the annotations calculus or whatever
yeah okay so it sounds to me like this
is going to turn into the next meeting
in this series is you know the
annotations calculus and maybe you can
present what you've done with graphs so
far can we just comment on I think that
the casebook gavin's thing might be
slightly different by staring I also
mean image in Orion
most things that we have discussed the
problem so we have talked for the
notation calculus about spatial
operation like taking parts but the
problem is that we can change the
content of a string of an audio or
whatever so in that case I am not sure
if the annotation calculus should be a
different thing than the spatial
operations well women so you're saying
no notation at time T but you change the
content of time T no I understand I
understand so does the does the thing
fall off when the content has changed
exactly right so that's a good question
I mean so that applies to strings as
well does the annotation yeah what I'm
saying is that there should be two types
of operations one their spatial
operations where the content is
preserved but they are the how much of
the content is their changes and the
other one actually changes the content
yeah I get it but what's different with
graphs I mean hopefully we're gonna have
a graph replace one of these days which
can absolutely go and start okay then
it's the same I just wasn't aware of
Gathol place right I mean graph replace
no no this isn't complete in the sense
that that it it's so open-ended unless
we restrict it you know but there's
other problems if we restrict it well I
think that's going to wind up being
certain criteria which could be
functions testing functions that
determine is it going to drop off if
such and such a thing happens sure right
so I mean even the worst case which is
reminds me of some kinds of inheritance
mechanisms is you know actually
modifying the annotation so in other
words I mean that seems hopeless to me
so for example let's take the audio case
if you said Phil is talking and it
starts at this time and it goes for this
duration okay they go a string to an
audio tape and you cut off bills first
throat-clearing or whatever and you
still want the bill annotation to be
there but with a different duration get
what I'm saying
so in other words you're monkeying with
the actual annotation itself yeah you're
trimming both the audio and they'd
interval the where of the annotation
right seems that seems really tough I
mean the general case of that seems
really difficult but it's like you have
to then understand I mean unless okay so
one could imagine look look I mean this
is okay so just to to start this the
annotation calculus you know the first
point would be something like um let's
see um Anna what would be the right word
annotation preservation function too far
if this there's one detail that maybe is
relevant only for images I'm not sure
but it's not present for audio and
string the Fabian strings are like one
dimensional so we can constrain the
design to get for example starting point
and end point of intervals yeah images
it's 2d input graphs it's no T at all
this is a 2d is like is not are we
forcing that to be a rectangle that
could be a line and an image or a
polygon what if you want an ax t you're
a doctor you want to annotate two more
region of complex we already have I mean
we have image masks which are doing that
kind of thing but at least we have an
underlying lattice where we can say
these pixel values are these voxel
values in the case of a graph we don't
have that at all we just have a certain
set of vertices yeah um but I mean we
have sort of the annotation preservation
function which takes which somehow takes
the you know criteria for whether to
preserve an annotation with an operation
I don't know
that's I mean that's one type of thing
then we've got let's see yeah so that
most of these are the annotation
preservation question is also some case
where you actually have have more than
preservation like in the case of a cough
you happy with that cough you are the
vertex you still want the curve to be
weighted the weight is the property so
you need to actually create a mutation
there's on that so you depend on the
type of IC so there's there's also some
kind of annotation cloning yeah
intellectually I wasn't super sure but
we discussed rest briefly that was like
cold forming annotation utility it was
aggressively populating empty keys for
negative for example if you create and
you have a missing like shape that seems
useful because that that's that will be
useful for analysis I mean you've got a
bunch of sparse annotations and you want
to densify them so to speak because you
want to be able to do essentially a
transpose of the annotations and say you
know rather than having something that
says oh there's a speaker being
specified here there's an audio type
being specified here to know that there
wasn't a speaker in in one of those
cases um I think we need to wrap this
meeting it will be good if we can
continue this soon before we have memory
decay so to speak this is unfortunately
a complicated area in case we hadn't
noticed that before
but I think we're going to have
something pretty reasonable here and I
think in the end we're going to have you
know some kind of annotated string
construct that I suspect we don't want
to mess with the actual string head
itself and I don't know if everybody
wants to comment on that immediately
does anybody know enough to be able to
comment on how horrific that would be if
we did that John be able to make any
comment on that I mean it's I just
talked to the people who do this stuff I
don't actually do it so
okay maybe just before we leave should
we add somebody who's been more into
string in we should next time yes we
should add somebody who knows about the
string of a notation although maybe we
can dispatch that in part of the meeting
because I think a whole lot of it is
going to be about this whole annotation
calculus
and we're getting there very good thanks
a lot everybody thanks to the livestream
folk nice comments and by the way we are
doing another meeting that is being
live-streamed in about an hour so if you
want to check in on language
completeness and consistency meeting
that will start in about an hour and
otherwise see y'all soon